I just want to get a few super quick I'm
ATS this or that question tight perm or
mullet root Oprah hate firm mullet I
think I have a mullet now you're rocking
a spandex immediate hard for neck woman
leg warmers and XM leotards I like I
like looking at leg warmers like I do I
don't think I'm wearing have a Papa yeah
can't we do both yet squeezin so
certainly did Walkman or Gameboy walkman
walkman I love my game boy growing up
ASA fight to get five minutes on my
sister's I never had a game would wanna
and although I would like I would still
play a game boy today but I probably
wouldn't still listen to a Walkman yeah
yeah
neon okay stuff better oh yeah let me
see ya disguising everything with a good
rap me on Twitter is impossible to get
off yes we're still finding litter in
our bodies yeah the shooting of this
show glitter even though he's quite
hospice it is Miley bang on it's insane
like I real I was trying there was
there's a scene where somebody puts on
glitter and I was trying to show the
actor how to do it and I'd like in so
you just take it and use gouache and
then it was on my eyeballs part I mean
like two weeks
Madonna Whitney Houston when do you
Whitney Houston Oh Rudolph uh wouldn't
Houston Whitney I think I didn't hey
Madonna that's very hard that it - yeah
I'm on it legend
sure I like songs by both of them but I
like you know I can't commit I would
probably listen to Whitney more hmm
Whitney's voice yeah it's just like
every time I hear that cover that song
the what is that what up he cries I cry
Giraud round one
oh why am i just synonymous with bamboo
yeah for sure
when ya wham well I mean Duran Duran
clothes what did they do it hunger you
like the wolf yeah well I mean I feel
like when I think of wham I don't know
if I'm actually I'm more I'm like a
George Michael fan but I don't know that
I'm that way me I went for you go way
all right
yeah safe instead George Michael at the
breakfast Coppola Top Gun Breakfast Club
Breakfast Club
yeah I would say Breakfast Club isn't
top nine coming back they're doing us a
sequel yeah well I hope that PC makes it
appear as newcomers Cindy Crawford Oh
Claudia Schiffer sunny Robert Enke Cindy
Crawford
although Claudia Schiffer shall wing
late rolls thank you so much
she's really fun